and I got the shining you love Wow yeah
it's like they were horrible there you
go
believe it or not I got that first two
terminators I'll call a bum
I will they're amazing and I got the Toy
Story trilogy come on
I will so there you go there are some
okay movies in there ago I guess the
best er things and I'm at fault sorry I
don't want to rent children or paradise
or Garden State and watch them over
again oh wait you haven't seen children
of paradise you told me you were going
to you should get that you should get on
them yeah but don't you want to take
recommendations from me well if you
don't like friend in there die hard or
terminate don't do that I've given you
great recommendations before it's you're
curious to like see you like my sixth
favorite movie yeah well you can't even
watch all Gardens day which I'll never
understand you should have at least
finish day because you're obviously I'm
like an hour into it no Indu will I know
I know but I'm just saying you did like
Gardens day someone who doesn't like
Gardens daily deserves it seriously be
executed and further entire family but
that's extreme well as you said I
haven't seen it you haven't seen it yeah
well I can't officially sad and like it
then can i well you said you disliked
what you saw I did then for that you
deserve to die it was too artsy and
independent and look at me I'm an
independent movie for me too artists II
and independent huh there's just one of
those movies it's like hey I'm an
independent film so I'm clever just
because I'm an independent no make a son
stay I agree it's like I'll actually
have to write to make things things
clever I'm just gonna be an independent
film with funny little music playing
I'll let you go lately
that I didn't have that that I got my
brother to do in the garage so I'm like
me because I'm poor um Chris I owned the
Garden State sound right and I can
honestly say that every song it's
problem a band yeah but they're all like
independent indie rock bands I'm sure
Coldplay okay that's a legitimate The
Shins that movie kicked me in my
sorry for my corning ewer
I don't think an independent filmmaker
making an independent film being some
pretentious I agree
okay the noqreh say that Garden State a
look at me have an independent film you
know like there are independent films
that are like they think they're they're
just they're trying to be so clever and
functional yeah and not Hollywood that I
mean that's fine and everything but
don't be like a d-bag about it I don't
know what pretty sure Zach Brock was not
in was not a d-bag in his direction of
garden stages and - it was just too
Corky for me mmm that makes absolutely
no sense but all right well to me it
makes no sense that someone would be
able to find an irredeemable qualities
in die hard
now let's kiss please hey I didn't say
there weren't any redeeming qualities
and I noticed that it was overrated as
friendly it is um I like Bruce Willis
there you go there was good parts of
course I was Citizen Kane
just let the viewers know Blake and I
argue all the time we don't actually hey
together Chris is gay though if you want
me to be like when we're not recording
he comes on camera and tells me to take
my pants off and when I refused to he
gets angry giant sometimes he even calls
me offensive names have you ever seen
homophobic Batman you haven't no oh my
gosh type it in on the never mind out if
you see the life and death of club dude
yeah you should type it in on YouTube
right now it's funny but this if you
don't know Chris has an obsession with
like watching people or listen to people
wipe-alot YouTube videos that are his or
his liking I like to view people's
reactions to things that I either made
or like yeah that's exactly what I just
said thank you
right I mean it's kind of like a
filmmaker makes a movie and this whole
thing is showing the audience oh my gosh
tongue shall batches our review for
scream core is up yeah I can't wait to
watch that later I'm not gonna watch it
at all don't listen to him tom is just
trying to be nice that still looks
stupid no I think I look better the
second time around
yeah facial hair tends to grow on
thicker after you shave it Chris no it
just seems like he he you know cuts it
better it's very even last time it was
more like higher on one side
so like it looked weird are you really
over analyzing the goats you have top
channel but I suppose but only because
they're good sort of attention and
something that gets that much attention
requires analysis and yes people I was
kidding I did not dislike Tom channel -
I will maybe watch his review for screen
for later and I have a feeling he liked
it a lot I'm not really sure he's
unpredictable sometimes I think he did
cuz he was okay I'll I'm three hadn't
seen three in years like it not sense
like I watched all three of the screen
movies like in like 2004 or something so
it's been since then oh yeah I watched
all three of them for the first time
probably about a year and a half or so
ago I don't know like I really want to
watch the first year right now no right
now no no why not that one just like
reminded me of how better the first two
were because I have to watch number 23
oh yeah but don't watch that like series
like I watch I'm probably gonna watch
the thing tonight for the first time
which one the remakes that's good
like I had it I haven't seen either but
I heard I tend to hear more about the
remake so I just got that one instead of
those virtual they're making another one
though it comes up this year I'm so
confused here already yeah that's kind
of the thing where you have three movies
tell the thing oh it's apparently it's
it's a alternate title of the untitled
thing prequel so it's a pretty cool
uh-huh that's interesting
it's how the thing got in
and there's like no famous actors at its
advanced school you know that composer
Ennio Morricone oh my god I love it okay
he doesn't then score for that remake
that you're about to watch and it's
really strange because like it's
completely electronic but it's so weird
it's some it sounds like John Carpenter
did the score like he always does but
it's you know Morricone the guy who made
good bad and the ugly and always all of
his music is like pum pum pum pum pum
pum like what are you doing you're like
it's like a guy throwing a pearls before
swine or something it's a weird person
yeah you're getting you're getting a lot
of metaphors here tonight gosh you're so
sophisticated as intelligent yeah for
those of you who are dying to know
chris has an odd obsession with moving
scores and he doesn't like to face the
fact that the best movie score of all
time comes from Dear John just thinking
about it makes me pee myself in tears
like the only reason you say that
honestly is because I know you don't
really listen to movie scores that much
and you just found one you really like
then I bought the entire album yes you
obviously found a score that more than
likely is very pretty and well-made but
it's like it would be like me finding
one whatever music you listen to I can't
figure out what those are words yeah me
finding one metalcore CD I actually like
me saying it's the best metalcore CD
ever and you're like wow that's nothing
compared to that sir for one thing you
got act like I do not acknowledge what
you are saying I'm not actually saying
that Dear John is the best movie score
ever if I was actually like although I'm
not I do not have the interest that you
have but like put serious consideration
I would probably say it was jaws but I
don't know like not just like the jaws
theme but they altogether score of Jaws
yeah yeah yeah I cannot believe that you
you had the privilege of seeing that
basically as an adult in you're almost
18 and because I like I grew up watching
that so I mean I've always just seen it
you had the privilege of like
experiencing it as an older person it
was awesome in my and my best friend got
to experience the Star Wars trilogy as
an adult I'm so jealous so I had just
seen bits and pieces of jaws when I was
younger um I expected it to be given I
didn't really expect it like loved it as
much as I do
et I've never seen et I saw when I was
like five maybe and like I don't even
think all of it I said I seriously like
do not remember a single thing about it
except this kid just like crying it's
like a plant died or something and like
that's it I'll just walk almost watched
Mac and me instead that saw that
recently my friends and I am
I can't even know about that movie we
had me do a stupid movie night every
once in a while where will purposely
rent it a movie that we this looks awful
and well I'll just watch it and we we
got back in me it was amazing
I'm actually seeing it you know actually
a couple times twice hi what well I was
I was younger is like it was just like
on uh it was on one of the movie
channels like HBO or something a lot I
remember how just like be skip those
channels and they'd be on no just like
watch it although I don't like it I
don't know is that weird like that
that's amazing
but yeah the kid on the wheelchair and
his alien like like coke and skittles I
think fourth and the final seemed was
like the whole alien family like driving
like in this like pink convertible just
on the like la streets shows them in a
courthouse in suits being accepted by
the public legally and they have like
the weirdest expressions oh it's such a
horrible movie but yeah we watched top
dog that was our last movie we watched
Farrah stupid movie night it's Chuck
Norris he finds a dog and they become
friends they fight together
Chuck Norris did it yeah from they fight
crime it's horrible but I want to keep
you should watch the skateboard kid too
ready to PG for an adolescent punch in
the nose an adolescent punch in the nose
it's funny as a PG rating ever but
anyway um yeah this thing about top dog
that's horrible as they try to make it a
family movie but the villain the villain
of the film is a group of white
supremists
what I'm not kidding the built the main
villain of the film is a giant group of
white supremist who go around trying to
kill black people and it's Chuck Norris
against them
and they're trying to they were trying
to make it a family film and I just
didn't even think about this at all yeah
I'm reading the plot right now with his
with his cop companion shot killed by
terrorists Reno the dog pairs up with
tough cop Jake and Warren the criminal
organization is directed by Eric Norris
yep as a brother it's a family event
the film event of the year is now the
family of it doubly here I walk by that
poster today at the theater did I'm
laughs yes of course I did that the
poster is stupid I really just want a
picture like this happy just not the
Jones's stereotypical and there
good family walking in to see the King's
Speech oh really it's like dad dad guess
what movies coming the theater The
King's Speech